>> Okay Michael, what did you come up with?
>> I have a bunch. Well, so, the big advantage of ICR, RCA, it's cheap.
>> It is cheap.
>> It's simple.
>> It is simple.
>> It's easy.
>> It is easy, in a sort of comical or complexity sense.
>> Sort of practically free. Those are all
words like, free, easy. Those are, those are
the words that came to mind. You're saying
that that's, none of those is your word.
>> No, none of those was the word that I was coming up with.
>> How about, works?
>> No.
>> It did start with the letter f, though.
>> Famous.
>> No.
>> Foul mouthed.
>> That's two words.
>> Friendly.
>> No.
>> Alright, I need more letters. I'm
still going back to famous. Fabulous. Fast.
>> That's right, it's fast. But I would
give you, definitely give you cheap or easy.
>> Cheap
is like fast.
>> So is easy.
>> [LAUGH] Alright.
>> [LAUGH] At least your, that's what the slang term meant
where I grew up. Anyway, okay, so anything that captures fast,
cheap, easy, whatever would do here. But what's irritating about this
and actually things like k means and k and n and
a whole bunch of other algorithms, is that they're so freaking
simple, and yet they manage to work. And that can be
kind of annoying sometimes because, you know, as machine learning people,
we want to come up with these complex things that work,
but as a very brilliant man once said to me,
you must earn your complexity. So, RCA, randomized components analysis,
or really randomized projections, has this very simple way of
thinking about the world. I'll just randomly throw things together,
and it turns out to pick up correlations on the
way and worked pretty well. And its big advantage, other
than working sometimes, is that it's very, very fast. PCA
can take hours in supercomputers, and ICA can take hours upon
hours in even more supercomputers. But
generating a bunch of random numbers, computers
are really good at that, and it happens to go really, really fast.